Lost Tapes of what I don't know talk to
me like I know what I'm about to react
oh hello guys
Ryan right here and Breanna white here
where did I get this knife oh I don't
know
where did I get this knife nobody knows
but know we'll be seeing dan cyber
around for a while top five unknowns
they have presented five creepiest lost
tapes which were found like around
Halloween I was watching a lot of these
guys and then it started putting me in
like a dark place yeah cuz it was like
too much reality of dark stuff that
exists so one blind denial like 99% of
the time yeah I got 99 problems but
blind and nail hello
there's much one it's called going with
the joke you know you messed up on the
word in these stores just make a really
loud announcment they've messed up the
word and then move on comedy lessons so
I know one with Iran right leadership
a lost tape is video footage of an event
in which the person filming lost their
camera and it was later found by
authorities or just a member of the
public in this list we take a look at
some really creepy tapes that were found
number 5
Croatian stalking it's believed that
this tape was found in Croatia on the
4th of October 2005 the tape simply
shows two teenagers filming themselves
in the video the team behind the camera
explains that the camera is new and that
he is testing out the teens then go on
and film themselves doing random things
such as parkour after this they noticed
a shadowy figure in which they believe
is a man urinating they then see the man
get closer and noticed that he has a
sack over his head believing the managed
drunk they approach him the man goon
begins to chase them it's believed that
the teens went missing and the camera
was found by Croatian police who
released the footage to the public to
see if any leads would come up however
this has never been confirmed number 4
Pennhurst footage that some clips aren't
too creepy but the backstory behind it
is known as Pennhurst state school and
Hospital is located in Pennhurst
Pennsylvania it opened in 1908 as an
institution for mentally and physically
disabled individuals in 1968 it was
exposed in a television news report
called suffer the little children a
reporter went into the hospital and
showed children living in terrible
conditions in 1983 of his exposed fat
the staff would badly assault the
patient on a regular basis this led to
the place being shut down in 1987 as it
was ruled that the conditions at the
Institute violated patient's
constitutional rights the abandoned
building remains up today and many
people visit it as it's believed to be a
paranormal hotspot this footage was
filmed in May of 2008 recorded by two
college students it shows them exploring
the hospital it's badly decayed and
there is creepy writings on the walls
such as a pentagram the footage itself
isn't too creepy but it said that the
cameras found near the hospital and the
whereabouts and fate of the students
remain unknown they could have just lost
the camera
but who knows our number three but your
house story tapes the Bjork store cup
otherwise known as Ricardo Lopez was an
American pest control officer who is
obsessed with Icelandic singer björk he
became obsessed with the singer in 1993
after learning about Bjork's
relationship with fellow artist Goldie
Ricardo became jealous and grew
increasingly angry he then decided to
try and kill Bjork
by sending a letter bomb rigged with
sulfuric acid to her home in London
after dropping the bomb off at the post
office
he went home and committed suicide he
filmed the entire event months before
this he started a video diary he
described the purpose of it in his own
words as this my life my art my plan
comfort is what I seek and speaking to
you I am being my own psychologist you
are a camera
I am recorder in total there was 11
video tapes which held two hours of
footage each as they progressed his
anger towards Bjork increased and he
ended up stating that the only solution
was to kill her towards the end of the
tapes he showed himself making a letter
bomb he originally planned to create a
bomb filled with contaminated blood
which contained the HIV virus he soon
gave up on this idea and created one
filled with sulfuric acid in the final
tape he filmed himself taking the bomb
to the post office in order to send it
to Bjork's address he then went home
painted his face sat in front of his
camera played a few Bjork songs then
committed suicide he committed suicide
as floater apartment by shooting himself
in the head he committed suicide as he
believed that if the bomb killed Bjork
then there would be United in heaven
police found his rotting body a few days
later as somebody complained of a foul
smell after viewing the tapes the police
were able to intercept the bomb York
commented saying she was very distressed
by the incident and she also sent
flowers to Ricardo's family number 2
Paris catacombs the Paris catacombs are
network of tunnels underneath Paris
which were originally built by the
Romans thousands of years ago it was
originally built to use as a mine but by
the 18th century
when cemeteries in Paris started to
become over packed the residents decided
to place the deceased in the catacombs
the network of tunnels and our filled
with skeletons the tunnels have a span
of 170 miles guided tours are offered
however only allowed to explore a
certain amount of miles as it is really
easy to get lost in 1955 it was made
illegal to enter the catacombs without
an official escort many years ago ABC
family done a special on the catacombs
in it they featured a clip the clip is
believed to have come from the mid 90s
it shows a man exploring the catacombs
alone while he was 228 feet below street
level he starts to feel uneasy and you
can hear his breathing become faster as
he continues to explore he comes across
paintings and after this he sees
something that terrifies him he then
begins to run and drops his camera but
he continued to record his camera was
later found the fate of the man remains
unknown today or he saw down there is
unsure but the documentary hinted that
he may have come across the gates of
Hell number 1 dead diver
Yuri Lipsky was in Israeli Russian
diving instructor on the 28th of April
2000 he died while exploring the Blue
Hole in the Red Sea the Blue Hole
located in the hub Egypt is a natural
sinkhole which is notorious for killing
many divers while diving at below 300
feet he began to suffer from nitrogen
narcosis this usually occurs in divers
who explore further than 100 feet
nitrogen narcosis is a change in
consciousness which occurs while deep
underwater it's been described as
feeling similar to being drum other
symptoms has been described as loss of
senses movement and numbness it's caused
by the effects of certain gases while in
a high-pressure area while at 300 feet
the narcosis will induce hallucinations
blackouts youth oreal and states of
extreme rapid depression this will
eventually lead to death Yuri was
recording his dive in the video you do
not see him died but you see moments
before his death you can hear his
breathing become quicker as
starts the panic clouds of salad then
visible as he becomes panicked and
thrushes around after this you can hear
the air begin to leave his lungs he died
shortly after thank you so much for
watching
enjoyed the video then be sure to give a
big thumbs up don't forget subscribe to
keep updated with our videos goodbye
how do maybe watch these things
sometimes I don't know why I watch these
things we're just going to talk about
the mechanics of the video I mean I felt
like some of them the second one I
didn't feel like was that creepy no
they're like Asylum one cuz it didn't
show anything but like someone drew the
Satanic thing on the wall I thought the
creepiest one was the very first one
with the guy with the with the thing on
his head in the limp he looked like a
demonic hunchback yeah scary it was
really scary that was totally creepy I
would have like hurt that guy why were
those kids playing around with him while
they were doing intense parkour right so
their adrenaline you know didn't let
them be scared something like that I
don't know dude
no I don't [ __ ] with things that look
like that looked like something out of
health but not only it literally crawled
it so yeah that was the worst video they
put that one first I know maybe they did
that on purpose because they want people
to watch the video fine
but then everything else after that was
kind of a letdown and then the catacombs
one was pretty scary but then they
cheapened it at the end by saying just
all the good it's at home it's just like
well no II didn't
how do you know have you been to the
catacombs no did you know that there's
been many people who have died in the
catacombs just exploring the catacombs
did you know that I don't know that but
I'm well it's likely that that could
have
and you're right the gates of hell that
doesn't make it the gates of hell it
does why would he'll be below Paris the
city of love oh because the devil loves
to hate the second you open the gates of
Hell there Satan jerking off ready to
[ __ ] you so hate it's Satan city of love
of hating something like that yeah all
right Paris arena you mean Paris has
prostitution and drugs and like
everywhere else yeah and that's why the
devil exists that's the proof
you said it now you know it's true
mm-hmm you believe everything you say
Liam yeah you catch me every Sunday like
I can on the PBS networking out goodbye
the Bjork guy was kind of creepy I was
really glad they didn't actually show
the shot the shot where he shot himself
oh my god that would have been district
like now when I watch these videos I get
so pulled it's like this dark world I
know
yeah it's really just when it's over on
my way cause there's real there's really
good around me and I need to be aware of
it yeah
the Bjork guys stalker he he looked like
Dan Seibert no he didn't that's not fair
to see he looked like Dan Seibert that
[ __ ] we was doing his face his high came
on to Brianna when I was 17
hey Rihanna as you can see I was clearly
in love love to take you to Tony's pizza
with my teeth though you gotta lift your
gums up wait what do you know that thing
yeah like that yeah it's pretty good
pretty good meditation there
Oh God alright dad it's totally dan
Seibert it looks like dance brother it
looks like it could be Dan's brother who
do I look like Kate Moss you look like
an angel Brianna with minions Brianna
you must defend our city I do not fight
with humans that is your own war but
they challenged us to death I don't know
where this is going imagine the story is
enjoying this this looks like slightly
Maleficent meets Game of Thrones oh you
know I would watch that i watch the
shout of that I only do you got it you
know I just feel my feelings and I see
what that leads me the dead diver one
umm what's sad about hearing that was it
sounded kind of fun oh they made it
sound like some sort of dig trips like
you're going uniter taint your uh is
something I'm like you drunk or yeah
hallucinations your experience su fought
you for eeeh
yeah back with rapid depression I guess
sound like shrooms but if you want to do
it the all-natural way you just dive
deep underwater
yeah that's not natural that's the
natural way deep down as he was that's
not natural it's natural it's more
natural than taking shrooms shrooms grow
from the ground water is where humans
come from the oceans not evolution I
just didn't feel like it was creepy
enough to be the last one
well it's moments before he died that
doesn't creep you out it does a little
what type of like cynic like it sounds
like you you're like looking for like I
feel like you wanted to see that footage
of the guy shooting himself no no no I
just felt like with what they recorded
in the first one yeah like I I'm just
repeating the idea that after the first
video they showed the rest of them were
a letdown
you know I was looking for some sort of
you know they kept setting it up for
like maybe you'll see some paranormal
shadows or whatever alright
but then it was just actual death and
that is not fun scary and sad that's
just sad scary and so of course he's not
gonna be fun scary I mean this is that
channel this channel isn't fun scary
like these are like we're here to
disturb you we're here to make you feel
uncomfortable I love it is five
creepiest not five saddest or like five
make you question your own reality Lost
Tapes you know you and Jerry would be a
good just saying just saying guys get
picky over weird things I'm not picky
yeah you are
I'm not yeah you are no yes you are not
yes you see you
de nada no me llamo Dora I don't know
where to go from that mmm movie but I
can just continue to say no no that's
okay listen guys if you needed the
channel you can subscribe today by
becoming a reject where else
Briana white hmm she has a gaming
channel sibling rivalry
pretty cool check it out definitely
check it out but I won't stab you if you
don't so like it's fine there's also a
playlist here for uh Briana white all
the video she's been on the real region
I mean quite a few now huh yeah you mean
white for you have you ever actually
used a straight razor no scared I get a
clarifying electric razor and it's
wonderful has you know many different
haven't used it obviously in a long time
but this computer is done and this
videos done everyone go down